react is a powerful tool for building
dynamic and interactive web applications
making it an in-demand skill set in the
front-end developers job market to meet
the demand and stay lock step with
today's technology udacity's react
nanodegree program encompasses what
students need to pursue jobs like
front-end developer
the react fundamentals course has been
updated to teach react hooks and testing
react components
students will go on a project-based
learning journey to build declarative
user interfaces ui components for web
applications using react making state
more predictable in their applications
with redux and make their apps more
efficient and robust using newer react
features and the just testing library
in this program students will also have
the opportunity to develop a mobile app
for ios and android using react native
building knowledge and confidence in the
react ecosystem can be challenging
udacity's project-based learning program
will give students the opportunity to
practice what they have learned
students will receive feedback from our
mentors on how to write powerful
applications and create components to
build complex user interfaces that will
engage customers enroll in udacity's
react and nanodegree program today
[Music]
you